willkommen an der
landesverteidigungsakademie in wien mein
name ist oberst andreas allex ich bin
forscher und lehrer für militär logistik
am institut für höhere militärische
führung in diesem video möchte ich sie
näher heran führen haben die logistische
unterstützung der russischen
streitkräfte
ich werde daher besonders darauf
eingehen auf die herausforderungen
nämlich den bedarf der streitkräfte
die distanzen den raum und die dauer des
krieges
die erste herausforderung ist der bedarf
der streitkräfte
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass sich ca 200
tausend russische soldaten in der
ukraine pcs im umfeld ukraine befinden
dann haben sie einen bedarf von circa
800 online verpflegung pro tag beim
kraftstoff der ebenfalls erdogan ist der
bedarf das sind circa vier millionen
liter kraftstoff für ungefähr 120
bataillons kampfgruppen die sich aktiv
und direkt an kampfhandlungen beteiligen
wie man es ausgeht dass eine bataillons
kampfgruppe für fünf tage autark ist das
ist für fünf tage
bestände mit führt dann muss spätestens
am dritten tag eine wiederauffüllung
passieren das muss organisiert werden
das muss auch bedeckt werden und da
jetzt die ukraine natürlich keine
logistische unterstützung für die
russischen streitkräfte leistet müssen
diese bedürfnisse der streitkräfte aus
der strategischen basis aus russland
nach geführt werden
unser kommen wir schon zum der zweite
herausforderung zu den distanzen und zu
dem raum also wie erwähnt die
strategische basis russland muss
leistungsfähig sein die strategische
basis russland bestehen im wesentlichen
aus der rüstungsindustrie aus der
zivilen wirtschaft und das militärischen
depots und lager diese müssen aufgefüllt
sind das wird sich in den nächsten
wochen zeigen welche auswirkungen diese
sanktionen der westlichen
staatengemeinschaft auf die strategische
basis haben
eine weitere herausforderung im bereich
der distanzen und woran ist die ukraine
selbst die logistik ist abhängig von
verbindungs den
straßen sei es eisenbahnlinien
verkehrswege oder sei es auch der
lufttransport wenn wir uns die ukraine
hier geografisch betrachten da gibt es
sehr viele leistungsfähige eisenbeil
ihren es gibt doch einige
leistungsfähige straßen und es gibt doch
zwei wesentliche c verbindungslinien
einmal nach odessa und einmal hier nach
mario pohl
eine herausforderung bei den
verkehrszahlen ist dass diese sicher
sein müssen erste strukturen in belarus
zeigen bereits dass es hier
herausforderungen für die nsn
behandlungs bord von morgen richtung
süden gibt eine zweite herausforderung
ist in den russisch okkupierten gebieten
hier in den blass rot dargestellt man
stellte fest und man stellt auch fest
dass die russischen streitkräfte keine
territoriale hoheit über dieses gebiet
haben das heißt es gibt nach wie vor
anschläge es gibt sprengung von brücken
und es gibt auch eine störung der
eisenbahn das bedeutet durch das prinzip
der kleinen nadelstiche
versuchen die ukrainischen verteidiger
die logistik die versorgung aller
anstrengungen der russische streit geht
es in diesem bereich zu minimieren und
das wiederum hat gewaltige auswirkungen
auf die kampfmoral der russischen
streitkräfte
sie müssen sich nur vorstellen wie
kommen sie zweifle keine es kein essen
wir kommen seit drei tagen essen
bekommen sich kein entspricht das heißt
die führung das vertrauen in die führung
schwindet massiv und das wird sich in
den nächsten tagen noch zeigen ihnen
wird dass die russischen streitkräfte
aber wieder ausgleichen können eine
zweite herausforderung im raum der
ukraine sind auch das schlechte wetter
sprengung von brücken und bedrohung
all das ergibt eine geringere
transportgeschwindigkeit wenn wir normal
davon ausgehen dass ein ton wo er auf
der autobahn 60 bis 70 kilometer in der
durch im durchschnitt fahren kann dann
verringert sich die geschwindigkeit auf
20 bis 30 kilometer pro stunde das hat
wiederum eine auswirkung auf die umlauf
leistung der
es müssen mehr fahren und die gleiche
anzahl an der menge zu transportieren
immer wieder kommt die frage warum die
russischen streitkräfte summer sich von
der snb abhängig sind nun das hat
natürlich zwei gründe der eine grund ist
natürlich kann ich mit der eisenbahn
größeren mengen größere tonnagen zum
beispiel an munition oder betriebsmittel
transportieren der zweite grund ist
wahrscheinlicher denn die russischen
streitkräfte die logistische elemente
der russischen streitkräfte verfügt
nicht über die erforderliche anzahl an
transportfahrzeugen und daher wenn man
sich die geografie des konfliktes hier
ansieht zb die angriffs richtungen und
die angriffsziele da stellt man fest
dass die masse dieser angriffe entlang
oder in anlehnung an wichtigen berlin
erfolgte wie zum beispiel hier im
südosten oder hier im norden daher sind
auch die verkehrsknotenpunkte also
elementarer bedeutung für die russischen
streitkräfte wie zb taktisch oder donets
in den letzten tagen ist der kampf hat
sich der kampf um mario pohl hier
intensiviert und zu gestern bedient auch
ein kampf um odessa warum diese zwei
städte und logistischen hintergründen
einerseits in seehafen der anbindung an
den seeweg und andererseits ebenfalls
leistungsfähiger essen bei lehnt die
hier versuchen nach norden verlaufen
der letzte punkt die letzte
herausforderung ist die dauer
anscheinend ist russland davon
ausgegangen dass es ein kurzer
angriffskrieg wird daher hat man
möglicherweise die bevorratung die
ausstattung der angreift in verbindung
mit logistischen ressourcen
vernachlässigt allerdings ist wohl auf
widerstand gestoßen
die folge war dass logistische basen
hier in den einsatzraum sprich in der
ukraine errichtet wurden sogar hatte man
könnte auch sagen pufferlager wir erst
der bedarf abdecken zu können
allerdings müssen alle diese
einrichtungen die sind hier nur
schematisch dargestellt
gesichert werden und auch diese
sicherung bindet wieder kampf elemente
die man für andere einsätze eben nicht
verwinden kann eine große frage das wird
sich in den nächsten wochen noch zeigen
wird sein welche auswirkungen auf das
zivilleben hatte die bedarfsdeckung aus
der strategischen basis russland wenn
man immer mehr ressourcen aus dem land
nimmt das aus dem euro aus dem
russischen heimatland und in die ukraine
nach führt wird sich hier möglicherweise
eine herausforderung für das zivile
leben in russland selbst ergeben
ja ich habe versucht in diesem video den
bedarf der streitkräfte die distanzen
traum und auch die dauer
darzustellen zu erläutern die
herausforderungen herauszuarbeiten
eines hat sich jedenfalls gezeigt und
das ist doch eine wesentliche folgerung
für alle logistischen maßnahmen im
bereich von streitkräften die
notwendigkeit einer gesamtheitlichen
integrierten planung einerseits im
vorfeld aber auch während eines
einsatzes ein operation eines krieges
ist wesentlich und zweitens die
verfügbarkeit eines lagebildes die
logistische führen muss zeitnah
permanent über ein aktuelles lagebild
verfügen um rechtzeitig maßnahmen der
logistischen bedarfsdeckung einleiten zu
können
damit möchte schließen und ich wünsche
dir noch alles gute